if we could clone ted you guys he would
love to work at lee canyon he'd love to
work and play there and then work and
play here too
right but that would be where you would
be hanging out your twin that would be
my doppelganger my doppelganger would be
ski patrol
villain
[Laughter]
yeah it is it's a blast and this weekend
should be nice there too really so go on
out there great hiking weather and i've
got more flow facts for you ready latest
one christian trying to sneak in and see
this one earlier but i kind of made sure
you didn't see it i tried it blocked me
get this jupiter is twice as massive as
all the other planets combined
that's how big jupiter is octopuses and
squid have three hearts did you know
that no i didn't know that either it's a
lot of love that's a lot of love and i
know people with no hearts
and they're no longer friends todd
todd lorendo
evil todd florinder ski patrol villain
all right 78 degrees right now for sky
canyon and centennial hill 77 for spring
valley 80 right now for north las vegas
so another above average day for us at
this hour and that's not going to change
that's not going to change until we get
to next week and i'm going to show you
that big cooldown coming up 80 and
whitney ranch mountains edge at 77 76
anthem double sevens for henderson
regional highs or temperatures current
temperatures right now we haven't
reached our official high just yet 74
degrees for indian springs
73 searchlight death valley are back in
the 90s again in 82 for loughlin right
now here's our satellite radar composite
because what you're seeing in the
pacific northwest is another atmospheric
river they've just been slammed with
more rain more snow in the cascades
there while this high is just blocking
us from all that what's going up and
over this ridge of high pressure but
this is giving us above average
temperatures what we've been seeing
lately but kirsten i know you love this
graphic so
oh yes
sunday 80 and then get ready here we go
we're going to go down fourth
later on the week
queasy 66 degrees thursday look at that
big temperature drop look at that 80 to
66 80 sunday thursday 66 that puts us
right near average we're going to show
you what's happening there on the eighth
day and coming up high our winds for
tomorrow shouldn't be a problem all
right this is where those winds should
stay fairly light in the las vegas
valley however if you're going to the
lake and you'll be going down river
laughlin as well and some of those areas
there down the colorado river it will be
a gusty day tomorrow 57 tonight nice
evening tomorrow 78 degrees sunny and
pleasant again 10 degrees above normal
eight day forecast shows the warmest day
on sunday after that those numbers start
to drop look at that down to the 70s and
then 60s next week more near average
temperatures that's your most accurate
forecast here on eight news down
ted can you get the temp to warm up in
here it's like a meatlugger
i'm on it i'm on it